il ne vous reste plus que quelques jours
pour vous inscrire sur les listes
électorales afin de pouvoir voter aux
européennes ces élections sont
programmées le 26 mai prochain en
plateau pour parler or ils iront demain
soir de la rédaction de tv 78 alors pour
les retardataires qui ont jusqu'au 31
mars minuit quelle est la démarche à
effectuer pour s'inscrire
alors vous avez deux options soit vous
rendez dans votre mairie avec une pièce
d'identité récentes et un justificatif
de domicile soit et bien vous pouvez le
faire directement en ligne
ça se passe sur le site du service
public cela ne prend que quelques
minutes
c'est un scrutin qui mobilise peu qui
est aussi mal connue à quoi servent ces
élections européennes alors on rappelle
les élections européennes ont lieu tous
les cinq ans et permettent aux citoyens
des 27 états membres de choisir leurs
représentants au parlement européen en
tout 700 cinq eurodéputés seront élus
dont 79 pour la france c'est simple de
plus sans que qu'en 2014
conséquence évidemment de la sortie
normalement bien sûr du royaume uni de
l'union européenne et pour ce scrutin
aurélie une nouveauté une seule et
unique circonscription il ya cinq 5 ans
notre pays avait été découpée en huit
circonscriptions régionales met donc
pour 2019 ce n'est plus le cas chaque
parti politique doit présenter une liste
de candidats pour l'ensemble du
territoire français vous allez voir
d'ailleurs le nom des têtes de listes
s'afficher alors bien sûr nous n'avons
pas pu tous les maîtres il y aura
notamment un manon aubry pour la france
est soumise le versailles et
françois-xavier belani pour les
républicains nicolas dupont aignan pour
debout la france yannick jadot pour
europe ecologie les verts ou encore l'ex
ministre désormais elle chargé des
affaires européennes nathalie l oiseau
qui conduira la liste est la république
en marche
sachez qu'à l'issue du scrutin les
partis ayant obtenu plus de 5% des
suffrages bénéficieront d'un nombre de
sièges proportionnel à leur nombre de
voix et notez également que le début de
la campagne officielle de ces élections
européennes débutera en france le 13 mai
à nous aussi on rappelle également
aurélie cette date butoir ce 31 mars à
minuit pour vous inscrire sur les listes
électorales merci pour ces précisions